[Music]
hello this is rocky nash your life
producer at channel 8 and we are here
with the famous john langler good day
las vegas live local and now
right famous famous famous i know you
watch kitty las vegas thanks for tuning
in monday through friday four to seven
a.m on that
but we are talking about fitness week
all week at 6am right yes 6am
good day las vegas fitness getting you
in shape put down the bowl of cereal
put down the toast with butter and get
in shape you may not know this about
john
but he is big into hockey tell us about
it so uh
if you're a long time viewer of good day
las vegas hopefully you know
uh that i've played hockey my whole life
i talk about it frequently but yeah i've
played hockey
since i was five years old which was
many
years ago i started when i grew up in
new jersey and then when i moved to las
vegas started playing here as well
and i love it and that is how i stay in
shape and it certainly is a workout
you're using core muscles you're using
it's a ton of
cardio workout and there's just the
competition of sport that
i find interesting so what i do because
i'm really against
gyms um so much either i know
i've done yoga frequently i used to do
yoga a lot more
but i don't really consider a gym that's
a class but um
i play hockey sometimes up to three to
four times a week
and for me you know i'm i play hockey
with my
my fat my pals here in town uh there's
competition involved we all kind of get
along too
and uh you know it's fun it's a fun
thing
let's see some footage there's some
house footage there's a hockey
tournament that i played in
over at city national a couple of uh
month or so
that's me right there going back i play
defense i've played defense almost my
whole
the whole time i've been playing which
is gosh 35 years i've been playing
hockey i guess i started when i was five
when i moved to las vegas when i was a
kid i was 16 there was the rank up at
the santa fe i used to play up there
this is us going down not scoring a goal
but i played at the santa fe all the
rinks in town and
for me it's about when when i want to
stay
fit it's i have to have
some level of motivation and the
motivation being in a gym i get bored i
get bored
running on a treadmill running outside
is a different deal but
being in a gym bores me and playing a
sport as i'm sure you at home can
attest whatever sport it is basketball
football golf whatever it is it you
shouldn't get bored
and for me i like the fact that
hockey doesn't bore me so that's what
i've played uh
my whole life is hockey and
the good thing about hockey because it
becomes so popular because of the golden
knights
there are a ton of ways to get involved
whether you're
an old geezer like me or you're a lot
younger you're a kid
that has learned to play options uh in
town
all over the place um at city national
arena out in
summerlin there's the new lifeguard
arena in henderson there's las vegas ice
center which is i think
flamingo and fort apache on the west
side of town there's the fiesta up
at well at the fiesta it's the pepsi ice
center now
there's all sorts of camps and ways to
learn and ways to get involved you can
get some second-hand gear because it
does get a bit expensive
just get on the ice it's a challenge
but it's a lot of fun and that's how i
stay fit a little fit as a relative
oh wait we have some more footage we
have some more photos right here is a
little fashion show of you
fashion show proof of my hockey playing
days that's over at city national arena
uh that's from when i used to play up in
seattle when i lived up there and that's
the team i played on uh at the the
tournament a couple of uh
i guess a month or so ago in las vegas
it's it's so important to stay fit and
especially you know
on good day las vegas we're talking to
you while you're getting ready in the
morning
and you're dragging yourself out of bed
and you're like oh you got to go to work
you got to go to school whatever the
case may be and so finding time to work
out is so
important the group of people that i
play with here in town
we get ice time at different parts
during the day so it's like in the
middle of the day it'll be
at noon it'll be you know there's always
a time to play
it's hard to find sometimes but there
are
places to go to do it so if you're
interested in this in playing ice hockey
and being the next member of the golden
knights there are ways to do it and
finding
a way to squeeze it in between your work
schedule whatever the case may be they
have places
at city national we used to go out there
for live shots when the golden knights
went to the stanley cup final
you can be on the ice there i think five
in the morning
you can go stick stick and puck at five
in the morning play for like an hour
just the same as an hour workout at the
gym but you're on the ice you're
sweating you're skating around and then
you can you know go to work or whatever
the case may be
well thanks for all those tips thanks
for sharing the behind the scenes
footage of you
on the video on the photos that's
what'll make me famous not the news
stuff it's the hockey player
we'll tune in for more of that on john
social tell us where they can follow you
uh i'm at john underscore langler on
instagram
uh john langley reporter on twitter and
john langler tv i think on facebook
don't worry i'll tag him
with this video we're gonna also post it
on social so thanks for tuning in
on how we say fit let us know in the
comments how you stay fit and tune in at
6 00 a.m all week this is the thing
this is what we're talking about thanks
john thanks for joining us
you